[Musique]
vous êtes en pleine répétition pour un
projet complètement fou le spectacle
Rome d'une durée de 6 heures vous
reprenez cinq textes chics supérieurs
sur la violence sur le pouvoir sur la
démocratie comment vous vivez tout seul
ouais c'est une bonne question
mais en fait ça fait tellement longtemps
que j'y songe et que je me prépare que
dans le fond j'ai pas vu l'énormité de
la chose mais j'ai dégusté par petites
bouchées donc à la base je pense j'avais
ce goût de travailler
j'expire bien sûr c'est banal mais mais
aussi travailler spécifiquement des
pièces qui traitent du pouvoir et la
démocratie c'est très exigeant au niveau
de la discipline personnelle parce que
c'est il faut
que je sois très en forme j'ai quand
même 72 heures donc bon en même temps
c'est bien que j'ai l'âge que j'ai parce
que j'ai la maturité pour faire ça mais
c'est demandant
par toi et ton passé violence pouvoir
démocratie ce sont vraiment des thèmes
qui vous ont été chers pendant toute
votre carrière absolument absolument
[Musique]
de femmes qui étaient allées à l'époque
où je voulais faire ce métier et qui
était quand même on était pas si
nombreuse donc j'ai toujours dû me
battre j'ai subi quand même beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de pression aussi donc
peut-être c'est le thème qui m'intéresse
je sais pas ou peut-être c'est pour des
raisons plus intimes plus personnelles
j'ai été élevé dans un milieu très
autoritaire très très dur donc vous êtes
une des plus grandes batteurs en scène
au Canada votre histoire est fascinante
parce que vous êtes né à Versailles en
France vous deviez être pharmacienne à
25 ans vous quittez tout ça pour
déménager en Ontario ensuite il y a eu
le Québec plus tard bien entendu alors
pourquoi ce dém pourquoi ce départ ce
changement de cas
je pense que pour moi mais ce que je
vois avec le recul si j'ai l'impression
que je pouvais pas me développer comme
artiste sur le territoire
disons de mon père pour dire simplement
ou sur le territoire français embarque à
l'époque je sais pas si j'aurais pu le
faire non plus
c'est des circonstances ça veut dire on
attrape on attrape un fil qui passe ou
on le rejette j'ai attrapé le flic qui
passait puis je suis arrivé en Ontario
français j'ai vraiment je suis tombée en
amour complètement avec avec un peuple
une histoire
c'est extraordinaire quand même c'est
des années
foisonnantes riches toutes sortes de
rencontres le hasard a voulu que c'est
entrevue soit enregistré pendant la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes et ça c'est un thème qui vous est
vraiment cher parce que tout au long de
votre carrière vous vous êtes battu pour
à la place des femmes au théâtre ça pas
toujours été évident pour les films
d'avoir des postes de direction théâtre
quel chemin reste-t-il à parcourir mais
c'est sûr que en apparence on pourrait
dire que ça quand même évolué par
rapport à l'époque où j'avais 25-30 ans
parce qu'il y a beaucoup plus de femmes
on pose de direction maintenant je
trouve que c'est loin d'être fini des
jeunes étudiants de l'École nationale de
théâtre me disait elle me disait elles
ont 20 ans elle veut dire
comment ça se fait que moi quand je
parle on m'écoute moins que quand c'est
mon gamin donc il y a encore du chemin à
faire
mais je suis quand même heureuse de voir
des jeunes femmes brillantes
Catherine Vidal Catherine bourgeois etc
qui ont qui ont accès aux institutions
on n'avait pas à l'époque
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression de mieux
vous connaître après avoir lu votre
dernier roman qui est paru chez Boréal
sombre et la nuit mais vous parlez de la
société patriarcale justement dans ce
livre-là tout vos thèmes chers ils se
retrouvent c'est vrai vous avez raison
parce que aussi ça traite d'une époque
quand même que j'ai bien connu parce que
j'ai fréquenté Vincennes l'université de
Vincennes et tout ça ou c'était quand
même le royaume des intellectuels
machistes c'est
donc oui c'est ça c'est des thèmes qui
me sont chères qui je pense que c'est
inconscient aussi surviennent c'est pas
ok je vais je me dis pas je vais aborder
ces questions là de francs en fait ça me
rattrape végétarien merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup à vous
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]